but between matrices in this
case, the matrices M and N.
So let's take a few moments
to discuss tensor products of matrices and then we'll
return to this question.
Here's the definition
of the tensor product between matrices and
it's very much analogous to the tensor product between vectors.
If we suppose that the two
matrices that we're working with are written in the forms that you see here so that the entries of M are
denoted alpha ab as a and b
range over some classical state set sigma and the entries of N are
denoted by beta cd as c and d
range over some classical state set gamma.
Then the product of M and N is the matrix that you see right here.
What we have is similar
to the tensor product between vectors.
the rows and columns of M tensor N correspond to pairs of classical states which are written as strings right here,
and the entries are products of the corresponding entries of M and N.
Here's another way of writing it in terms of the individual
entries of these matrices.
The ac bd entry of M tensor N is the product of the ab entry
of M and the cd entry of N.
There's another way of
describing M tensor N, which is that it's the
unique matrix that transforms any vector of the form Phi tensor Psi
into the tensor product of M applied to Phi with and applied to Psi, and that has to be true for every choice
of these vectors Phi and Psi.
One way to think about
this is that the tensor product of matrices gets along perfectly with the tensor product between vectors.
This is an equation that you
would naturally hope is true and indeed it is.
In terms of matrices that
are written out explicitly, we can define the tensor
product as you see here.
There's a lot of dots in this equation and they're meant to
illustrate the pattern, which is the same pattern
that we had for vectors except now we have rows and columns
as opposed to just column vectors.
In case it's not clear, the
following example may help.
Here we're talking about
the tensor product of two two by two matrices.
We first write down four
copies of the second matrix, one for each entry of the first matrix.
We multiply each of these
copies of the second matrix by the corresponding
entry of the first matrix,
and then we collect it all into
a single four by four matrix as you see right here.
We can also define the
tensor product of three or more matrices in an analogous way and perhaps the easiest
way to express this
is as you see right here
where we have a formula for each entry of the tensor product, which is simply the product
of the corresponding entries.
You can also define the tensor product of three or more matrices recursively in terms of the tensor
product of just two matrices just like we had for vectors.
And one final note is
that the tensor product of matrices is multiplicative, which means that a
product of tensor products
is equal to the tensor
product of the products.
You can think about
this as a generalization of the formula from a few moments ago for the action of intensive
product of matrices
on tensor product of vectors. And again, this is something that we
would certainly hope to be true and we can be glad that it is
and we'll make use of this
fact whenever we need.
And now we can return to
the question from before which asks how we describe
the effect of performing an operation M on a system X
and an operation N on the system Y together as an operation
on the compound system XY.
And the answer to that
question is that the action is described by the
tensor product of M and N.
Tensor products represent independence this time between operations as opposed to what we saw
before for probability vectors.
Here's a quick example. Suppose that we perform
the probabilistic operation described by this matrix on a bit X.
This happens to be an operation
that we saw in lesson one and we simultaneously perform
a NOT operation on a bit Y.
The combined operation on the pair XY is therefore represented by the tensor product of the matrices corresponding to these two operations.
Here's the one on X and
here's the NOT operation on Y and we get this matrix
that you see right here.
And you can see that indeed
this is a stochastic matrix and that will always be the case.
The tensor product of any
two stochastic matrices or any number of stochastic
matrices for that matter will always be stochastic.
It is a very common situation
that we encounter a situation in which one operation is
performed on one system and nothing is done to another system.
In this situation, we follow exactly the same prescription with the understanding that doing nothing is represented by the identity matrix.
For example, if we have two bits X and
Y and we reset the bit X to the zero state, which is the same thing
as performing the constant
zero function on X and we do nothing to Y, then the resulting operation on the par XY